[Music]
thank you
do we need a Multiverse I I believe so
for many reasons
the first one being We Know by
observations that our local Universe did
have a beginning so that that
immediately implies that there is
something else Beyond research and and
before that particular beginning if with
the caveat that that time exists before
our universe did
so in in that case of course it's hard
to believe in a cosmos with with an
eternal time with a fundamental time
parameter that the only thing that ever
happened for eternity was just one pop
our universe and nothing else so it's
quite natural that one of the expect
many structures to to exist beyond the
structure of our universe and and that
is a extension of the copernican
principle we are simply saying not long
ago we thought planet Earth is the
center of the universe and then the
solar system and now we are saying even
our local universe is not the center of
the cosmos we are just one humble member
somewhere in in a vast beautiful and
complex Cosmos so that that to me makes
sense the the other reason why I
over a decade ago took this idea of the
Multiverse seriously is because whenever
you you probe these questions of the
origins why did we start with this
universe that question does not make
sense if you don't have an ensemble a
pool of possibilities from which to
choose from
if all I uh all I have in my pocket is I
don't know 10 pounds then it does not
make sense for me to ask what's what's
the probability that if I put my hand in
my pocket I'll pull some other notes
that is not 10 pounds of course there's
a hundred percent probability that the
only thing that will come out is 10
pounds or nothing else and and uh the
same with the universe if you insist
that we must have only one Universe then
um I I do not see how the question why
did we start with this universe can make
sense
and and that if you dig deeper
um that that really boils down to two
very fundamentally different approaches
to to the nature of our universe in
theoretical physics one is the approach
of The Theory of Everything a single
Universe an underlying theory that of
course ideally you can write on a
t-shirt but an underlying theory that
tells you absolutely everything you need
to know about this universe alternative
approach is the Multiverse the
possibility that the cosmosis is more
complex and and the second that the
letter also allows for an
indeterministic Universe one that is
based on on probabilities and and the
first one is is based on a deterministic
universe so these two very different
tastes to physics also determine the
kind of one Universe versus many
universes approach But whichever way
people go I mean uh
eventually we'll all be forced as we
solve one problem after another after
another will all be forced to to merge
into one point of view and uh and and
hopefully that will happen soon
[Music]